With reflection mapping, we get sharp reflections. This is good as far as it
goes, but many reflective surfaces are glossy. They're shiny but they're not
mirror like, reflections are a bit blurred. One way to simulate this effect is
to blur the reflection map. This blurring is usually done in advance and the
texture stored. Some cleverness is needed to properly filter from face to face
of the cube map, but utilities exist that perform this function for you. Think
about the Blinn-Phong specular reflection model for a moment. Blinn-Phong and
other reflection models work by taking the lights direction in eye direction.
They use these to decide at a point on a surface how much that point is likely
to be a perfect mirror, whatever portion is a mirror reflects this light. In
reality, much of the world most of the time is sending photons to any given
point in space from many different directions. Look around and everything you
can see is sending light your way. It doesn't matter if the light is from an
emitter or a surface, except that emitters are usually brighter. What an
environment map does is treats the whole surrounding world as a source of
light. While blurring an environment map is not entirely physically correct, it
is extremely convincing. There is less of a problem of a reflection not
matching up with what's in the environment, since you can't see a clear
reflection on a burnished surface. Another advantage is that these blurry cube
maps can be considerably smaller in size and still look good. For the two cube
maps I showed, the original had faces that were 512 by 512 texels in size, the
blurred version only 128 by 128. A lower resolution is all that's needed since
the color changes more slowly. If you want a wider range of materials, you can
blur the original reflection map by different amounts and get different gloss
textures. You can also mix and match between sharp and blurred reflections on
the same surface, giving an impression of a multi-coat material. Combining
these ideas with different reflectivities, illumination models, and surface
colors can give a wide range of effects.